[Musique]
direction 2002 pour ce nouveau numéro 2
ça s'est passé et déjà se pose la
question des déserts médicaux comment
assurer une permanence de soins pour les
habitants en octobre montigny le
bretonneux inaugure sa maison médicale
de garde la première du département des
yvelines elle l'idée un lieu unique où
les médecins se relaient pour assurer
les gardes pour les passions c'est la
garantie de trouver rapidement un
spécialiste et nous étions présents lors
de cette première nuit de garde
il est 20 heures le docteur alain jamie
entame sa première nuit de garde en
maison médicale une première dans le
département trois ans de réflexion d'un
groupe d'une quarantaine de médecins de
montigny voisins et guyancourt
si l'expérience est concluante ce sera
la fin des visites de nuit à domicile
dorénavant les patients se déplaceront
ici dans un local de l'ancienne école
jacques prévert
il ya de moins en moins de remplaçants
il y a de plus en plus de deux médecins
qui vieillissent et que la charge de
travail qui est liée à la prise d'une
garde ça représente 36 heures d'affilée
où on est censé être opérationnel comme
si on avait dormi correctement et donc
on n'avait pas travaillé la veille du
lundi au vendredi de 20 heures à 24
heures le samedi de 14 heures à 24
heures et le dimanche de 8 heures à 24
heures le numéro d'appel unique ne
change pas mais au bout du fil ce ne
sera plus le médecin mais le 15
s'il relève de notre compétence dans la
structure qui attend on si tu l'appelles
nous est pas lancer le régulateur du
terrain donne le code d'accès au saas et
les patientes peuvent rentrer en sonnant
à l'interphone mais c'est à paris on est
on est complètement dans l'expérimental
là ça c'est clair
oui ouais
fausse alerte toujours rien cela veut-il
dire que les patients ne veulent pas se
déplacer
après vérification les régulateurs du 15
confirme qu'aucun appel n'a été passé sa
première soirée calme
[Applaudissements]
une nuit de garde tranquille d'autres le
seront sans doute moins mais les
médecins libéraux ont en tout cas le
sentiment d'avoir réalisé en ce 1er
octobre
une première qui qualifient d'historique
ça s'est passé se poursuit et nous
restons dans le domaine médical avec
l'ouverture cette fois-ci de l'ufr de
médecine de saint quentin les locaux ne
sont que temporaires nous sommes en 2007
mais cela concrétise le déménagement de
quelques 700 étudiants de garches à
saint quentin
l ufr simone veil n'ouvrira qu'en 2010
au coeur de montigny le bretonneux
mais cette installation à guyancourt été
est indispensable dans des locaux
préfabriqués en raison de la vétusté et
de ceux des hauts-de-seine du nouveau
depuis cette rentrée pour les étudiants
2e et 3e année de la faculté de médecine
paris ile de france ouest désormais ils
n'étudient plus à l'hôpital de garches
mais à guyancourt boulevard d'alembert
près de l'université des sciences
humaines de bâtiments sur billancourt a
été finalement choisi dans l'urgence
puisque notre faculté médical qui se
trouvait donc à garches donc mais qui
était rattachée auparavant à paris cinq
n'avaient jamais eu des des locaux
adéquate et en fait ils étaient dans des
locaux amiantés chemin de type pailleron
et j'ai pris la décision donc l'an
dernier de fermer ses locaux 600
étudiants donc investi le 3 septembre
les nouveaux bâtiments préfabriqués
composé du deux amphithéâtres de 150
places six salles de cours et des
bureaux de l'administration
coût total des travaux 800000 euros
financée par l'université de versailles
saint quentin et par la communauté
d'agglomération à hauteur de 200 mille
euros c'est un jour important puisque
guyancourt est une ville universitaire
et avec les bâtiments les bâtiments
temporaires de médecine c'est une
nouvelle étape
nous avons eu depuis 1985 et tout
premiers étudiants en des yvelines était
à guyancourt que nous avons eu des
bâtiments leclerc d'alembert
vauban et aujourd'hui l'université de
médecine les bâtiments sont neuf donc
comparé aux anciens bâtiments qu'ils
avaient avant à garches ya déjà du
progrès ce qu'ils étaient un peu en
ruines donc moi je trouve ça pas mal qui
est le les préfaces deuxième et
troisième années qui sont ici et c'est
ainsi que nous refermons ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire ça s'est passé revient à
partir de vendredi tous les numéros sont
à voir en replay sur notre site internet
[Musique]